what's going on reject nation Greg Alba
here we are wearing our headphones so
early this is Meghan McNulty people you
might have heard me talk about already
in some videos go check out her channel
the tiny to Turkey is a tiny tiny human
being tutoring skills for your children
and for you to be a better parent I'm a
tiny bean I'm 411 for 11 and a half is
that legal little person is not and I'm
good good good I mean it won't be bad
racist against little bit yeah there's
this new movie out called Papillon which
stars Remi in Malick he's so amazing
Charlie Hunnam to TV show stars coming
together let's see the updated modern
gritty version of it yeah
[Music]
Legrand with the wrong guy also through
come on let's go yeah he always does
that boy this is a pop right money get
some never escape without a million
[Music]
whoa whoa keep me alive I'll endure any
escape you can arrange something tells
me you can do quite savage
you are the property of the penal
administration of French Guiana there's
no way up snows away
I know many of you are thinking about a
steak this is your best chance feel free
to try whatever you like emeritus come
with you there are two Guardians who are
always Beauty Bush what a best thing
that can happen to you is starvation boy
you could choose to see what workshops
always be any manage to survive your
first attempt you'll get two years in
solitary a life sentence at Devil's
Island
[Music]
strange things happen there especially
to have something to help
this looks crazy
[Music]
- in 10 3 no I mean I got some tears I
mean I got some serious nipple chills
from that it's about not being in but
getting out and do they get out like it
felt like there were like seven escapes
having not seen the original I saw the
original movie which starred Dustin
Hoffman and Steve McQueen yeah that was
a little boy I don't remember the
original that well I just remember it's
a prison escape movie and I just receive
McQueen's suffering a lot in that film
it doesn't seem too far off from in
terms of plot points okay they just keep
trying to escape and Steve McQueen just
keeps getting caught and he just keeps
suffering he's talking about you're just
gonna happen next here's gonna happen
next and they can--it Rose not showing
you a lot of those plot points yeah you
get put in solitary confinement you get
starve you go crazy the biggest
difference I notice about this trailer
as compared to my vague memory of the
original this sim seems like it's taking
a much bigger approach in terms of the
emotional tone the haunting experience
of which is yeah it seemed like putting
you in the emotional state of those care
I know it's common for people to hate
the idea or the concept of a remake but
this one seems like it's probably
offering something different which is a
more psychological deteriorating
experience like a haunting experience a
visual aesthetic that feels very
different than the older other one has
got it I just really relies heavily on
like you know watching Steve McQueen and
Dustin Hoffman do a great freaking job
with their performance they are - but
you have this backdrop like you're
saying yeah it's kind of funny to see
like Charlie Hunnam taking up the role
of Steve McQueen's Charlie Hunnam is not
the most respected actor and it's like
see McQueen it's like a legend
you know so to have Charlie on I mean
you're right or you can wonder if
there's a backlash with that but he
looks like he's doing a good job
I feel like Grammy Malick is probably
gonna be the one who steals the show in
terms of performance you know I mean I
instantly connected yeah that
juxtaposition of the the gorgeous
backdrop and then Bonnie said that
Devil's Island the funny quick story my
husband is a Marine and when he was in
marine boot camp they called it Devil's
Island Road where he trained the main
guy drone structor would be like the
only way off this island is to do a
death meaning like you can't get you try
to get out you're gonna end right back
in seams similarly we will not get out
it's almost like in he the only way to
get out is like through your own head
man this journey looks rough it looks
like a rough thing to sit through this
feels like it could be unsettling and
uncomfortable which is like a kind of
movie I couldn't enjoy the character
experience is look good I connected
right from the beginning I'm like well
what happened and what happened to her
and like what's that story that's
probably the motivation to get off well
of course I like movies that are like
haunting but have a beautiful
cinematography and that's kind of the
vibe I get like this looks really pretty
but also kind of unsettling as hell I
think the biggest obstacle to overcome
is is gonna be Charlie Hunnam
performance because to match the caliber
of a legendary actor like Steve McQueen
when Charlie Hunnam doesn't have the
greatest reputation he's got the build
yeah you know he's sexy he's sexy I kiss
him that's all I do
well you got it skids quick notification
bells and hey if you're a parent who is
stranded in a prison but you want your
kids to learn stuff have them watch the
tiny tutor YouTube channel see how I
made it all come full circle seamless
eight years of improv will teach you how
to do to the head people yeah that's
pretty good everything I know
see yes and not really yeah just say
yeah yeah and it would you all right
yeah [ __ ] to you later